today for our daily cancellation we're
going to cancel the cdc
uh it's a long past time for the cdc to
face its cancellation
there have been many straws straining
this particular camel's back
the straw that finally broke it is this
as you can see the center for disease
control has a whole page on its website
giving guidance on holiday celebrations
because of course in a free country the
first thing a citizen ought to do before
observing a holiday is check with a
public health organization
and consult a series of federal agencies
before deciding how to celebrate it
this is why in my household on you know
our tradition on christmas morning is
that we all wake up early in our
early in the morning in our christmas
jammies yes i have christmas jammies and
yes i do call them jammies what of it
and we all wake up we go downstairs we
gather around the christmas tree
and then we submit an application to the
department of health and human services
requesting a waiver that will permit us
to open presents and usually it only
takes about two to three business days
to come through and
the kids really enjoy it it's a lot of
fun now in any case here's the cdc
um and this is this is them explaining
their guidelines it says as many people
in the united states begin to plan for
fall and winter holiday celebrations
cdc offers the following considerations
to help protect individuals their
families friends and communities from
coven 19.
these are considerations meant to
supplement not replace any state local
territorial or tribal health and safety
laws rules and regulations
with which holiday gatherings must
comply when planning to host a holiday
celebration you should assess current
covet 19 levels in your community to
determine
whether to postpone cancel or limit the
number of attendees
then it proceeds to give guidance on all
fall
holidays and it lists those holidays as
rosh hashanah
yom kippur halloween de a de los muertos
navratri diwali and thanksgiving so i'll
have to consult their diwali
guidelines later but here's what it says
for halloween
it says avoid these higher risk
activities to help prevent the spread of
the virus that causes covet-19
says um and then here are the high-risk
activities participating in traditional
trick-or-treating where
treats are handed to children who go
door-to-door having
trunk or treat where treats are handed
out from trunks of cars lined up in
large parking lots
attending crowded costume parties held
indoors going to an indoor haunted house
where people may be
crowded together and screaming going on
hayrides or tractor rides with people
who
are not in your household using alcohol
or drugs which can cloud judgment and
increase risky behaviors
traveling to a rural fall festival that
is not in your community if you live in
an area communi
an area with community spread of coven
19. so those are the things that
you must avoid according to your public
health overlords
but not to worry they do provide some
low-risk
safe alternatives these low-risk
activities
include carving or decorating pumpkins
with members of your household and
displaying them carving or decorating
pumpkins outside
at a safe distance with neighbors or
friends decorating your house apartment
or living space
doing a halloween scavenger hunt where
children are given lists of halloween
themed things to look for while they
walk
outdoors from house to house admiring
halloween decorations at a distance
having a virtual halloween costume
contest
having a halloween movie night with
people you live with
having a scavenger hunt style trick or
treat search with your household members
in or around your home
rather than going house to house okay
yes decorate your home for a festive
halloween party
and then invite no one over just sit
there in your living room
alone staring at the wall weeping
quietly while gorging yourself on fun
size snickers or as i like to call it
a normal tuesday night now these these
suggestions are are helpful from the cdc
but i'm afraid they may be giving us too
much latitude
some of these activities seem very risky
in fact like carving a pumpkin
there's the obvious danger that the
knife might slip you might disembowel
yourself accidentally
i have two cousins and an uncle who all
died that way
it was a bloody night which you know it
wasn't such a bad thing i guess given
that it was halloween
but also when when you go outside to
place your pumpkin on the porch
can you be sure that at the same moment
your neighbor might not be walking to
his car across the street and then cough
and a stiff breeze might carry the
coveted virus directly into your
nostrils
you know you might say well then i'll
wear a mask well of course you will but
then the virus might enter through your
eyes and then you say well then i'll
wear a face shield
okay fine but the virus might go into
your ears or it might attach yourself to
your clothes and then later that night
while you're getting changed for bed it
might leap into any number of exposed
orifices
now the risk of any of this happening is
somewhere in the neighborhood of like
point zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero one
percent but
it's not non-existent there is some risk
and what we've learned in recent months
is that we simply cannot afford to take
any risk of any kind at all
ever period unless of course you are not
a lunatic
and you prefer to actually still live a
human life you selfish bastard
and maybe you've come to terms with the
fact that you're mortal and uh risk will
always be there and
eventually you will die probably not of
covet but of something
so hiding in your home huddled under
your blanket
is not only a pathetic and dreary
existence but ultimately futile
you're going to die anyway if that's the
case
then you will go out and still
trick-or-treat because quite obviously
you know
in all seriousness trick-or-treating is
not high risk at all
you're outside kids are the ones doing
it
they aren't likely to contract or spread
the virus anyway they're already wearing
many of them masks and gloves for the
costumes
they aren't bunched together in tight
groups their interactions with people
answering the door are brief
if this is high risk then literally
anything is
which brings us back to huddling in our
homes under the blankets
what i can say is high risk or not
i will be out with my kids
trick-or-treating on halloween
so you better answer your damned door
because we're coming and if you don't
answer we might throw a brick
through the window though we would only
be doing that
of course for racial justice and peace
and because we're mad you didn't give us
any candy
which i'm increasingly convinced is also
the motivation behind many of these
rioters
they're just mad that we're not giving
them candy
but the cdc is uh is cancelled finally
for all of that
and halloween they say halloween is
canceled i say
it's a go congratulations you're welcome
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated